good evening welcome to Quayle rich
books in music we're so pleased that we
have such a good crowd to hear about
this extraordinary book and it is
extraordinary I'm constantly amazed at
the judgment and the decisions good
decisions of Algonquin books to publish
these wonderful books they publish but
this one took me to a higher admiration
particularly of Shannon Ravenel under
whose imprint the book was published but
I can certainly see why she did it I
wish you were here to tell you herself
but she'll be here later for you to talk
to after the program I was astounded
when I read this book I would evoked so
many emotions in me that I thought I
didn't want to do this because I would
probably get emotional but as you can
see I'm perfectly calm and I'll tell you
about Tim Duncan and he will introduce
our other honored guests Tim was born
was raised in Washington DC and the
Chesapeake Bay Area the settings for
both of his novels will tell you about
those he graduated from the University
of Maryland with honors and from
Georgetown University Law School and in
1977 he began his legal career as a
district of columbia public defender he
defended in several notable murder
trials before becoming a national trial
lawyer in private practice he has taught
at the writers Center at Georgetown
Harvard Law School and American
University where he received its adjunct
professor of the Year award
Kirk is the author of two award-winning
novels grand
I'm sorry Good Counsel which was
published in 2000 and the watermen in
nineteen
9 they got great reviews they were very
exciting reads and they were novels this
is his first nonfiction book let me just
read a couple of brief reviews of this
book from Scott Turow it says the story
his story blood war story it's not only
memorable and important but gripping and
revelatory more than anything
Bloodsworth is a tale of courage and
determination in the face of the laws
worst nightmare the execution of an
innocent man Joseph Wambaugh the
esteemed writer says Bloodsworth may
well be the most incredible and
important true story ever written about
a death-row convicts daily battle for
survival both in the cellblock and in
the courtrooms the reader will be swept
along to an amazing and shocking
conclusion that could never be believed
as fiction there were many other stored
reviews and just excellent reviews of
this wonderful book I would like for you
to welcome Tim Duncan
Nancy thank you so much and thanks to a
coil reg books and everybody else is
supported this event and thank you all
for coming out tonight we appreciate it
very much
Kirk and I have been in the
raleigh-durham area now for two days we
appeared at UNC Law School yesterday
spoke to about 300 young law students
and I think perhaps Kirk particularly
made them think about things they never
thought about before and perhaps the
going to do a little better lawyers of
all those things out at Duke Duke Law
School as well and made the same
reaction it's a real thrill figure with
Kirk and I think you are in for a real
treat when you get the opportunity while
sitting to go from him eventually turned
away now we're on c-span so I have a lot
of friends here nine I don't want any
technique from I am as Nancy alluded to
like I grew up firmly on the Eastern
Shore of Maryland which is the
Chesapeake Bay Country and the term for
a Chesapeake Bay fisherman or crabber is
a Waterman and I actually spent a year
trying to be a Waterman before
sort of rounds of college but it was way
too hard so I opted for something a lot
easier and went to law school
Kirk of course is a little warm in all
his life and comes from of that has
generations of Waterman I my first book
was called the Waterman my first novel
my second book was set on the bag as
well and I've always had an affinity and
interest in that area and in those kinds
of people I remember that I had been a
public defender and I just started a
private practice I've been in private
practice for a few years was about 1984
and I heard this story I heard a press
report that there has been an Eastern
Shore Waterman from Cambridge ground
we've been arrested and charged with the
rape and murder of a little girl and
having spent many years with Waterman
and with those kinds of people perhaps
it was a bit naive of romantic on my
part but people who live on the water
who are part of the the rhythms of the
bay and the natural world I just it just
seemed incongruous to need to try that a
Waterman would commit crime like that
and I just didn't believe it but I was
very busy in Washington DC building up
my law practice and I kind of lost track
of the story after I written my second
novel I was sort of casting around I
wanted to do a nonfiction book and I
came across an article it was about 20
years later I still wonder that and it
was about that same Waterman it was
about how he had been exonerated he had
been convicted of the crime sentenced to
death exonerated and it talked about
what a difficult time he was having
coming back into his community from
prison
it got me thinking uh since Kirk was a
Waterman I you know I had that interest
I had worked on death penalty cases
myself I knew the criminal justice
system pretty well so I contacted Kirk
Bloodsworth really knowing very little
about his story and asked him if he
would consider working with me on a
project of writing writing what had
happened to him in a book I told him
that I would want to have artistic
control and try to write a very
objective story of what happened his
cooperation and agreed to make it a
collaborative effort and after some
discussions I took them to Waterman and
your life that thought that I perhaps to
understand some things about him to
others might not and we started to drown
yet there were you gotta have my cheat
sheet here there were so many things
about food
Ariane's for me first of all I didn't
know about the circumstances of the
crime
in 1984 in July on a warm summer day
around 11 o'clock in the morning in a
suburb of Baltimore a young girl it was
nine-years-old who was named Denise from
Hamilton dawn Venise Hamilton without
playing with some friends around 11
o'clock in the morning her mother went
out to find her or her guardian went out
to find her and couldn't again looking
frantically for her in the area came
across two young boys ages 7 and 9 and
asked them if they'd seen Don and they
told her that Don had gone into the
woods with a strange man
thorns Guardian called the police
eventually over 200 police officers were
involved in a search for Dawn
tragically about 3 o'clock that
afternoon they found her in the woods
she was brutally murdered she'd been
sexually assaulted her head had been
crushed her throat had been stepped on
so that there was to the point where
there was a footprint in her throat she
was naked from the waist down a large
stick had been thrust up inside her it
was a monstrous terrible crime and of
course the community was horrified
terrified and the police indicated that
they were going to pull out all stops
the entire police force was going to
work on solving the crime the FBI would
be involved it was it was a very tragic
moment at around that time Kirk
Bloodsworth was a decorated Marine who
had never been arrested for anything in
his life he had married a woman ten
years older than he was and it was a
brief marriage and a difficult marriage
and they lived in Cambridge for a little
while and then his wife had left him and
gone to Baltimore and he had followed
her up to Baltimore to try to patch up
the marriage and been up there for
approximately three weeks when this
murder occurred
he lived in a group house with his wife
and some of her relatives about a mile
away
he was walking everywhere he was the
only one in the house who worked because
she had wrecked a car but he knew
nothing about the
until he heard about it on television in
researching the book another thing I
didn't know when I first met Kirk
Bloodsworth was was how people always
say to me how could a man who had never
been arrested in his life how could such
a man be targeted arrested indicted
tried convicted and sentenced to death
for a crime he didn't commit I was able
to gather together thousands of all the
thousands of the police reports there
were over 300 tips that came in to the
police department and there were
literally thousands of police reports
police notes police interviews all of
the FBI forensic reports the pleadings
the grand jury transcripts the trial
transcripts and I try to piece together
in the book for the reader sort of from
the minds of the two lead homicide
detectives in this case how they came to
believe that this man committed this
monstrous crime and they did come to
believe that the two boys two little
boys gave composite drawings the
composite drawings were disseminated in
the community there were inconsistent
descriptions of the assailant that they
gave eventually the police located a
number of adults who they claimed saw
the strange man by the pond that day by
the boys but the book traces how these
police officers and their zeal to find
this person not with malice they were
trying to find the killer but came to
believe that the wrong man did it and
then how they began to contort the
evidence adult eyewitnesses were
contacted the weekend before the lineup
right after Kirk Bloodsworth was
arrested and they were told we're going
to have a lineup on Monday so don't
watch the television this weekend
because if you do you might see the
suspect what do you think these
eyewitnesses did several of them were
glued to the television so that they saw
this man and handcuffs and shackles
surrounded by police and then when they
went to the lineup on Monday who would
they recognize
the book traces unfortunately the many
kind of classic mistakes that police and
prosecutors make in cases like this
withholding of evidence poor
identification testimony they got Kirk
Bloodsworth to make some statements
which were consistent with innocence but
which they interpreted to be consistent
with guilt to the point where they ended
up believing that he was the man it was
an FBI psychological profile done in
this case back in 1984 profiling was a
very new art and the FBI tried to
develop a psychological picture of the
kind of sick person who would commit
this crime and the psychological profile
conveniently or coincidentally had
things in it like well probably someone
who hates women probably someone who is
dominated by an older woman the man who
did this will probably leave the scene
within a few days after the crime things
like that one of the tips that the
police got was filed by his wife when
Kirk left her she was so mad she filed a
missing-persons report they called up
Kirk's job they found out he'd left two
or three days after the crime they found
that he was married to a woman ten years
older than him they began to misuse
really what a psychological profile is
supposed to be used for all of these
little mistakes one after another and
you can see as you read the book how
they became so convinced this man was as
guilty of this crime before Kirk
Bloodsworth I been hundreds of people
said to me you know innocent people
can't get convicted of these crimes and
they certainly can't get convicted twice
this book shows that that's wrong
when I first met Kirk Bloodsworth I
didn't know much about him yet he was an
Eastern Shore ornament I knew but his
history as a decorated marine as a
discus thrower his aspirations for the
future and then what happened to him on
the very night that he was uh arrested
and thrown into this horror that went on
for ten years I didn't know that when
the judge after his first trial
sentenced him to die in the gas chamber
but a courtroom more crowded in fact in
this room erupted in cheers and applause
people screamed give him the gas give
him the gas as he fell to his knees
wondering how could these people be
cheering I'm an innocent man when I
first met Kirk Bloodsworth
I didn't know that he had been tried not
once but twice for this crime and
convicted by two different juries two
different judges after Kirk's first
trial his family his father his mother
they mortgaged their house they took out
their life savings his first lawyer was
a court-appointed lawyer after he was
granted a new trial because of
prosecutorial misconduct because
prosecutors withheld exculpatory
evidence the first time around about
another suspect his parents took
everything they had to hire what they
thought would be the finest lawyer in
Baltimore County who promised Kirk that
he'd be out having a steak dinner as
soon as the second trial was over the
second lawyer entirely different
strategy in the case if you read the
book you'll see the first case the rally
by witnesses that were character
witnesses Kirk testified in the second
trial lawyer decided to put none of
those people on to simply just to try to
attack the government's case case they
try went on for two weeks same verdict
guilty when I first met Kirk Bloodsworth
I had no idea about his experiences in
prison thrown into one of the most
violent and notorious prisons in the
United States the south wing of the
Maryland penitentiary where a week
before he got there a guard had been
disemboweled by an inmate over perceived
insult so that the guards when Kirk got
there all wore knife vests
here he was thrown into this environment
branded a child murderer a child killer
he was everybody's target and after
about two months they put him out in
general population Kirk opened up to me
about some of his experiences in prison
in the book details some of the things
he had to do to survive and the
environment he lived in and it is truly
bone-chilling stuff I don't think
anybody can read the book without asking
themselves could I have even survived
this let alone triumphed over it when
Kirk Bloodsworth was in prison his
lawyers appealed his second conviction
and that appeal was turned down he lost
and it seemed like all hope was over for
him second judge have it was troubled by
the evidence in the case and so sentence
Kirk instead of to die he sentenced him
to two consecutive life sentences the
second judge was so disturbed by the
evidence
in addition that he kept the the clothes
the panties and the shorts of Don
Hamilton and the stick in a closet in
his chambers because he knew that after
the second appeal once it was denied
that in a matter of time the evidence
would be destroyed and he thought to
himself even though DNA nobody knew of
DNA back then that maybe one day someone
might need this evidence
Kirk story in fact is full of these
little miracles you read in the book
that at the first trial the FBI tested
the little girl's shorts and her panties
and an FBI agent came into court under
oath and testified that there was no
identifiable sperm on any of the clothes
now get back to that in a minute what
Kirk Bloodsworth did was every single
day of his life in prison he wrote
letters he wrote thousands of letters
everyone would sign Kirk Bloodsworth a
period I period em period and innocent
man he wrote them to everybody he could
think of he never stopped telling
everybody he met that he was innocent he
never gave up and he finally got in
touch with a man named Bob Moore and it
happens to be a
undermine a principled man is now a
judge and he convinced by morning to
come see him and Bob Morin was busy at
the time and was actually seen Kirk for
a friend but after 45 minutes Kirk
convinced Bob Morton that he was
innocent of this crime and Bob Morin
took on his cause that was in 1989 and
around that time Kirk read a book he was
reading avidly everything you get his
hands on it might help him he read a
book by the california crime writer Joe
wamba about the first use of DNA to
solve a criminal case it happened in
England and Craig read this book and he
thought to himself you know maybe maybe
this is the miracle I need and he
contacted Bob Bob's first reaction was
Kirk there's nothing to test
there was no sperm the FBI tested all
the clothing there were swabs taken
there was no sperm there was no foreign
blood and Kirk said you know Bob I want
you to pursue this I want you to follow
it up I want you to check it out and Bob
more and found the clothes it still
existed in the judges closet in his
chambers and convinced the prosecutors
in the court to let him have it sent out
to the for this new developing science
called DNA and in fact there was a new
DNA technique at the time and one lab in
the country then you had to do it where
you could take a small small piece of
biological specimen and amplify it into
enough so that you could test and they
sent it out to that lab in California I
took about three years of battling with
the prosecutors and with the courts and
getting the tests done Bob Moore the
lawyer put up $10,000 of his own money
his own money to have this test done and
it came back and the the PhD the
scientist in California said there was a
semen stain the size of a quarter right
in the middle of the girls panties and
it was not Kirk Bloodsworth
when I first met Kirk Bloodsworth I
didn't know that after he was loud a
prison
the prosecutors this was in 1993 instead
of apologizing issued a statement they
had a press release and they said this
evidence calls into question mr.
Bloodsworth guilt but we're not prepared
to say he's innocent that's the press
release but the prosecutors issued Kirk
Bloodsworth went back to Cambridge
Maryland people in Cambridge Maryland
didn't know what DNA was they thought it
was another legal quick step you know
some fancy legal trick to get him out of
jail they thought he was a murderer a
child killer people left messages on his
truck child murderer child killer
people chased him out of neighborhoods
when he tried to work the Kirk wasn't
satisfied and just triumphing over the
injustice that was done to him he felt
that he was joined at the hip with this
little girl who was killed they were
double victims of this crime and he set
out to solve the crime itself and he
began pestering the prosecutors to take
that DNA that he and Bob Morin had
discovered and put it in the county
database or the state database or the
national database and let's look for
this person this this monster out there
who might still be killing other people
they wouldn't do it ten years went by
ten years of Kirk Bloodsworth writing
them calling them getting lawyers to
hound them until enough pressure build
up and there were there were articles in
the papers and lawyers were calling them
but they finally agreed to put the DNA
in the database I was halfway through
writing this manuscript and we didn't
know who the killer was and I got this
call from Kirk and he was shaking and
crying they finally just a year ago put
the DNA in the in the database and it
identified the actual murderer
incredibly it was a man who was in
prison in the same prison tear as Kirk
Bloodsworth who lifted weights with Kirk
Bloodsworth for five years
kirk saw that solve that crime that man
pled guilty this past March and admitted
that he killed Don Hamilton by himself
in 1984 finally Kirk an apology from the
prosecutors when I first met Kirk
Bloodsworth probably the most incredible
thing of all as I learned or I learned
as I was working on the case and learned
it from him and about him was what he
has done with his life after coming out
of prison you know most of us I think
after an experience like that would be
so bitter so angry alcoholic just just
to destroy life Kirk has become he's
turned his life from being one of a
victim of the most profound type of
injustice into being one of our nation's
great spokespersons for justice he goes
around the country in the world now he's
appeared in front of Congress a dozen
times he's in P reappeared in front of
half of our state legislatures speaking
he's working right now on legislation in
Congress that has passed the House and
is pending before the Senate part of
it's named after him to try to provide
DNA testing from inmates who meet
certain criteria who might be innocent
and also to provide funds for DNA for
tests of rape kits there's 300,000 women
out there who've been raped and there
are rape kits of their of their
assailants with their DNA and the states
say they don't have enough money to test
them that means 300,000 rapist on the
loose
300,000 victims who can't get justice
and those are the kind of things Kirk
Bloodsworth works for and that's what he
does this past March the man who
invented the DNA fingerprint Sir Alec
Jeffrey's was honoured in Great Britain
with Britain's Lifetime Achievement
Award in front of a televised audience
of 10 million Brits and they flew Kirk
Bloodsworth over to London to appear on
stage with Sir Alec Jeffrey's and that's
the kind of impact he has had he speaks
at law schools he's trying to teach law
students not to make a mistake
that these prosecutors made he's trying
to teach young lawyers who are going to
be prosecutors it's not about
gamesmanship it's not about winning that
there are higher more important goals
and duties if you're going to be a
prosecutor if you're gonna be a lawyer
this is what he's devoted his life to
one of the people who reviewed this book
said you know what Kirk Bloodsworth did
to overcome what happened to him he's
truly an act of triumph but what he's
done with his life since is nothing less
than an act of grace and I think that's
true I'm very proud tonight to be part
of this book it's been a great honor for
me to work with Kirk and I'm proud to
introduce him tonight ladies and
gentlemen Kirk Bloodsworth I want to
thank Nancy and Quail Ridge books and
for having me here tonight it's an honor
and a privilege if you'd have told me 20
years ago I'll be standing in a
bookstore in North Carolina
I said you was absolutely crazy I want
to tell you a story about the first
lawyer I had there was in a visiting
room in the Towson Detention Center in
Baltimore County they had you know
little boosts and you get on the phone
and I know some people here wouldn't
understand what I'm saying
and it was a brick wall right behind me
just like this here
there's archway doors on either side and
there's no door there door 8-foot tall
10-foot wide you can walk right through
them or drive a car through so my first
lawyer comes up to me and he goes mr.
Bloodsworth I know my way around
criminal justice and I know my way
around a courtroom and I'm gonna find
our way out of this situation
keeps going on and on and on and I'm
starting to feel blue
disguise okay he knows his way around
the courtroom he says I know my way
around the criminal justice and I know
my way around the Baltimore County
justice system when or like just for 20
minutes finally he got up and put his
hand on the glass and said Kirk I know
my way around a criminal justice system
and we're going to find our way out of
this situation takes his coat grabs his
briefcase says goodbye turns around runs
right into the wall I'm done but on
August 9th 1984 it wasn't so funny open
up it's a Baltimore County Police
Department I was living down in
Cambridge over in the door and I had a
pair of shorts on silk running shorts no
shirt no she'd no shoes that was
sleeping this quarter to 3:00 in the
morning open the door and that guy
flatulating my face and said there he is
I turned right around looking for
somebody else honestly I did he says
you're under arrest for the first-degree
murder of Don Venise Hamlin Amal ttan
you sob huh no no sir no no no no no I
didn't do it I didn't do it I'm not
guilty I'm an innocent man
we don't want to hear that turn me
around put the handcuffs on me you have
a right to remain silent anything you
say can and will be used against you
they mean that when they say that - and
put me in the police car and I never
seen cambridge again for eight years 11
months and 19 days two of those years on
death row
I went to one of the hardest prisons in
the United States the Maryland
penitentiary 954 fourth Street there's
somebody in the back here I'm going to
introduce to him later
that knows about that place some I
sitting right up front here that knows
about how prison is well I went to the
first trial and the witnesses said that
they were looking for a man that was six
foot five curly blond hair bushy
mustache tan skin and skinny I was not
skinny in 1984 and I'm certainly not now
I weigh 225 pounds I was six foot tall I
was a lot leaner but I was far from
skinny I had red hair well the trial
come around all of a sudden demanding
six foot five no more he
six-foot-something burly funny how stuff
like that changes but there was two
little boys and you can't blame these
two little boys they were the witnesses
indication they saw the man sitting up
on a rise of a hill looking up at him
with the Sun behind his head they were
eight and ten years old neither one I'm
picking out of the lineup until two
weeks later saying no we made a mistake
one pick number three and other one
didn't pick anybody it was number six I
stood in the sixth position when the
police sketches artists we're putting
the composite together it's a set of
overlays it's called a dent kit and it's
made by Disney and it's a set of I set
of noses set of ears set of lips and all
that and the little boy looked at the
man is sick well I'm not happy with the
composite well why aren't you happy
about he said I don't like the mustache
the eyes okay but I don't like the
mustache and the hair is wrong and the
jaw don't look quite right he said what
kind of mustache was he says that one
right there and a man shouting to him
said that's a foo Manchu
little boy said I don't know where the
fu-manchu's is but that's what it looked
like on the police officers on his own
but the mustache that the boy didn't
like on the subject now I want you to
remember how six foot five we heard that
right and six foot on what you remember
that - and remember 225 pounds in
skinning because that's important also I
was convicted I was convicted with our
courtroom erupting as somebody school or
touchdown in a Carolina Panthers game
I'm a Ravens fan but I'm sorry but then
you know what I'm talking about and what
the heck am I going to do I'm going to
the Maryland penitentiary accused of
killing a nine-year-old girl and my butt
is in trouble the first night I was in
jail I heard this sound curb her we're
gonna get you and they meant that but
there I gave as good as I got it didn't
help me sometimes I got hit in the back
of here with a sock full of batteries I
seen I knew a fella by the name of blue
number blue don't you and blue was a guy
he was already known great for see he
admitted his guilt and blue hated prison
so bad that he took two pencils and
rammed them right in his eyeball to get
out of jail he I mean literally just
shoved them right in his eyes and he was
a guilty man how did you think I felt
but no I wanted to see because I wanted
to read I read over 3,000 books in
prison everything from Stephen King to
get start psychology forget that last
one because I can't understand it if I
told you
it's the driest thing it's my mouth
right now excuse me but I'm just a man
I tried to survive the best way I knew
how and reading was my thing that was my
escape I took a little Lewis and more
novels and Stephen King novels because
any horror story he wrote when near as
bad as what I was going through I read
everything I could get my hands on legal
papers anything about discovery anything
about the evidence in in how its
obtained how prosecutors are supposed to
act how they supposed to treat a
defendant anything and everything I
could and I wrote that many letters to
everybody in the state from Willie
Nelson to Ronald Reagan I never got no
answer for Ronald or Willie but I still
wrote and I wrote and I wrote and I
wrote I used to write the judge I said
it's Christmas Eve and I'm still in jail
an innocent man I period excuse me a
period a period in period every single
letter the prison the first night I was
there in the Maryland penitentiary I
remember being on the south wing it
needs to feed you up with styrofoam cups
and I had spaghetti that night but it
was a half board made in my cup and I
threw it back and ate it and just
started crying the door sounded like the
back of a dump truck falling down on the
back of the bed and slamming shut and my
life was over
you're talking to a fellow they went to
a Christian school in eleventh and
twelfth grade and never been arrested
for anything in my life
nothing never I was on be discharged
from the Marine Corps I was a discus
champion all marine jessyca champion for
three years now I'm not telling to tell
you I was angel with wings because I'm
certainly not true but I would now
killing an on you
little girl I got my case overturned by
a thin lining in law called Brady
evidence and that's exculpatory evidence
of tense and engage your guilt if
whether or not you committed a crime if
you have any evidence that says somebody
else did it they're supposed to give it
to you I mean that's the law they have
to give it to you if you follow motion
to say they you give us all the stuff
and don't hold nothing back what did the
state do they had another suspect they
came in the day of the murder in a
psychologic psychiatric clinic five
minutes away had scratches on his face
and was wearing the same clothes his
last scene of the person running away
from the scene said he had a problem
with a little girl they kept that
evidence for two years while I sat on
death row never told a soul as a matter
of fact he never told a soul until the
day before my trial was over on the
second time around and he said well you
should have asked for a continuance -
the lawyer again I was convicted the
second time I went back in prison in
1986 sat on the south wing looking at
the windows in this place I'm telling
you the south wing as Tim was saluting -
was a bad place they opened the windows
in the wintertime it'd be 30 degrees in
your cell in the summer they shot him in
to be 115 I had to live under that kind
of stuff and it's hard but I got harder
I just kept writing people and reading
and writing and I picked up this foot
one day that mysteriously come to myself
and you know that little company that
you can take pennies and get three books
or three records I've got books because
I didn't have a record player and so you
come to my door and I don't remember
ordered I had no idea that I ordered
those books I thought I ordered
something else
and the top of the book was called the
bloody about a book about the Norberto
murders in England to make a long story
short they DNA tested male population of
20 to 30 years of age in knauber Oh for
these little girls murders over there
and found a man by the name of Colin
pitchfork he confessed to the crimes BAM
I had an idea said whoa wait a minute if
I can convict somebody maybe I could
save you convicts a view I'm thinking
that way I was so excited I called Bob
morning on the phone I said Bob you've
got to help me there's this new thing
I've called DNA he said there's nothing
there he said but I'm going to write the
state's attorney's office and they got
some swabs and they got some evidence
and we're going to see what they got
they had oral swabs vaginal swabs and
some other things at like three or four
different kinds of swabs we got the
letter back from the prosecutor's office
do you know what she said I'm sorry to
inform you mr. Bloodsworth but the
Swami's have been inadvertently
destroyed I was done I just do it so
kept pestering Bob I called him every
day I bet he's got a phone build down to
the floor and that ain't no law I'm
serious I called him every day drove him
absolutely crazy he said you got to stop
calling me I said Bob when I get out
I'll stop calling you
so anyway I kept fighting I kept
fighting I kept fighting finally we got
the state degree to do all the DNA that
guess what it was in the closet
of the judge he was so upset by the
verdict as Tim said that he held that
stuff he told the the prosecuting
attorney in my case he said this isn't
about gamesmanship were playing this is
about the truth you have to speak about
the truth I knew I was on to something
we had to hold the stick I was talking
about and there's a I'm not going to get
too graphic for you because you had to
read the book because it's very graphic
stuffing I think I'll need to let you
read this book and understand because
she died a horrible death her head was
crushed with a rock her throat was
stepped on and her panties and shorts
were just discarded into a tree and this
stick I was talking about was inserted
in her body so fortunately it passed
through a part of her Anatomy
it's a god-awful thing to have a
nine-year-old little girl and have that
happened to her but I think we need to
find out who the real person was and I
was always under the feeling that if I
found that guy you know that six foot
five guy I was going to get get my
justice justice so we did the DNA test
in 1992 in DISA this next part bothers
me very much and I can't it's hard for
me to talk about it even to this day on
April 27th 1993 we got the DNA test back
January the 20th my mother died and I
did see her picks up in handcuffs and
shackles for five minutes in front of
the casket that was my life I thought it
was all over him I didn't even want to
live no more I really didn't but she
would have wanted me to do something
else because she knew her son and I'm
just a man folks I'm just a man I'm no
different than anyone y'all sent here
but I knew I had to live and I knew had
to prove that truth I've talked about so
June 28 1993 I stepped out of Maryland
penitentiary a free man they dropped all
the charges but the prosecuting attorney
in her dropping all the charges said
this if we had to evidence in 1984 we
would never have prosecuted mr.
Bloodsworth but we are not prepared to
say he's innocent now how in the world
do you believe that the burden of proof
is on the state they should not throw
the burden of proof on an innocent
person again but they did and they did
it for 11 years after my release I
begged people I talked to Barry Scheck
and every lawyer I could find please
please get him to do the dakotas test
please do it
we had to threaten him with soot we
don't have the money they said I'll pay
you the money I'll give it to you out of
my pocket please try to do this you know
I'm not against law enforcement I was at
Marine Corps military police officer you
do something wrong got to pay the price
that's my motto that's always been my
motto my parents my father's motto you
do something wrong you got to do it
excuse me
so what was I going to do I had to go
out get a job what are you going to do
when you go to a job have you ever been
convicted of a crime before yes but I
didn't do it well what do you mean I was
pardoned by the governor of the state of
Maryland I got three hundred thousand
dollars which comes to about nine
dollars and 97 cents a day for my
trouble
I have people at work putting child
killer in the dirt on my pickup I keep
it cleaner now but people were always
calling me and harass me people would
turn I had a lady in a supermarket when
Tom picked up a little girl and ran out
so you don't be around him he takes
children that was my life but then again
one day in September of last year
I mean 94 came 95 96 97 98 99 2001 2002
2003 I get this phone call sit Baltimore
County Maryland on my caller ID
who is that so I picked the phone up my
cell hello and this voice came on real
Stern and businesslike and said I like
to speak to Kirk Bloodsworth please and
I said who's calling this is an broke
says the Baltimore County Prosecutor's
Office the same woman had called me a
monster and sentenced me to die so I
said the only thing I thought I could
say at that point what can I do for you
she said I want to talk to you about a
development in the Hamilton case
okay she said I'll meet you anywhere but
I have to speak to you in person
you're not coming to my house so I did
anything I thought I would do I met her
at the Burger King and I did and I had
to look at the Choptank River that's
right runs right through Cambridge there
and that's where I crab bat or used to
I'm kind of busy these days but I was
crabbing there and had my boat right
there so I could take off and she was
coming back I wasn't going back to jail
but no I went there with my lawyer my
wife and my cousin we all went and she
we sat down on this table we joined
tables together and here's this woman
did hated me for 20 years
sitting in front of me eat more crowed
and then in these fields around here and
told me she said we got the real killer
we got and I said who is who did this
thing name was Kimberly Shana they're
not flipped right out I gave this man a
library book just like as close as I am
to you
he'd never staring me in eye he'd always
look like that or look away you know
what I mean look away scared of you you
know what I'm saying
worried anybody want to know how tall
Kim Lachey Ruffner was five foot seven
170 pounds and Kimberly muffler had a
foo Manchu
now my life has been real different
since then I won't stand for an innocent
person be in jail
never and on death Road no way happening
not while I'm standing on watch and I've
been to Congress every car every senator
in the US Senate has a copy this book
I've made some other senators give it to
him and they do - everybody's got a copy
and they passed out of the Judiciary
Committee this week a part of the bill
is called a Kirk Bloodsworth DNA testing
program and also to Debbie Smith backlog
rape kit testing program as Tim was
talking about earlier 300,000 rape kits
untested in California a couple years
ago they threw eighteen hundred in the
garbage can because he didn't have room
for them to store him anymore
as three hundred thousand victims three
hundred thousand rapists and three
hundred thousand families that are
suffering because we don't have the
money well this bill would give by five
hundred million dollars so we would have
the money twenty five million dollars
for the Kirk Bloodsworth DNA testing
program that will help states like North
Carolina defray the cost to help people
out of jail help people out of death row
you know this thing is simple for me
very simple
if
eleventh if I could go to Christian
school in 11th 12th grade with no
criminal record no criminal history no
nothing it's easy it's too easy for
people to play this type of game who can
win who can lose who puts on the best
show is who wins by the virtue if you
have $100,000 you're going to lose if
you've got nothing you're going to lose
he still might not win but he got a
better shot that you're going to lose
every barely winning talk to my family
for less than $100,000 my father don't
have that much money he worked all his
life he's 76 years old and can't retire
because it would happen it's this simple
if it can happen to me it can happen to
anybody in this room thank you
I'm gonna give it a sheet looking at
Crete Thank You Kirk you know the irony
of course is if the prosecutors from
Baltimore County Maryland and the state
of Maryland had had its way Kirk
Bloodsworth would have been executed
about 17 years ago and since Kirk fought
for his freedom and proved his innocence
through DNA literally hundreds of other
inmates since he paved the way hundreds
of other inmates who are in prison on
death row have been freed and proven to
be innocent and I think our entire
nation is beginning to wake up those are
just cases where DNA is available you've
got to keep in mind most cases there is
no DNA and those are just cases where
DNA is available and somebody's been
lucky enough to get a lawyer from an
Innocence Project like from the
University of North Carolina or from
Cardozo law school to take up there
cause it's pretty frightening when you
begin to extrapolate just how many
people we maybe can have convicted over
the past 15 20 50 hundred years who are
innocent and people need to appreciate
that when you convict an innocent man or
an innocent woman that's a victim it's a
victim of a crime just as much as
anybody else as a victim you have a
victim who's been wrongly convicted you
have a family destroyed the family of
that victim and you had a guilty person
a criminal walking free to criminalize
other people it's a serious run I think
we need to address and I think we should
be thankful to Kirk for what he's done
and the tremendous example he's set
we're going to take some questions a few
questions and answers but before we do
that we're honored with by the presence
of a couple of other people tonight we
just like to recognize and Kirk is going
to introduce them briefly
good if I told you
possibility of being more than one
innocent person in this room anybody
want to take a guess on that what if I
told you there was three here Alan Gill
spent nine years behind bars five of
them on death row waiting for his
execution for a murder he did not commit
Gail was sentences death for the 1995
shooting death of Alan ray Jenkins in
Bertie County no figures of evidence
connected Gale to the crime and he was
convicted based solely on the testimony
of two teenage girls who participated in
Jenkins murder the girls were allowed to
plea bargained for lesser charges
exchange for their testimony in 2002 or
rejections of the attorney general's
office and while a five-part series on
gales case is running in the news
observer a judge ordered a new trial
because this attorney general's office
had withheld Gil's trial attorneys
compelling evidence of his innocence
seventeen witnesses said they saw the
victim alive well after the only time
gal could have been involved in a murder
many of those statements along with an
audiotape showing that a key witness
plan to frame go were not shared with
the defense during gales trial forensic
experts agreed the victim died at the
time Gail could not have committed the
crime after the judge threw out Gil's
conviction and death sentence the
Attorney General decided to retry a girl
for murder the jury in his second trial
deliberated for less than three hours
before finding Gill not guilty in later
interviews jurors expressed surprise
that the state had retried yell On
February 18 2004 Alan Gill was released
in prison after spending nine years in
jail for a crime he didn't commit
he's Carolina's first death row inmate
exonerated stand up my land
and the third fella I'm not gonna be to
much fanfare for him he harden in the
back but that's Chris Conover back there
and he's he's listened resides here in
North Carolina
he was right into prison with me way
back when and knows some of the horrors
I was talking about tonight and I want
you all give him a big hand to Nancy do
we have time for a few questions okay
yes ma'am
absolutely you need to wait for the
you're gonna be on the TV well I read
the book this week you're an incredible
inspiration I wanted to thank you for
telling your story and my question is
did any of the other prosecutors or the
original judge or the police ever
contact you personally to apologize well
the original prosecutor in my case did
come down to the Burger King Hills talk
about sights her a couple police
officers but the two main homicide
detectives have never apologized in her
since retired and won't be won't let
nobody talk to him presses tried to call
them and I like know what you got to say
but about the first judge now
wanted to do that nope nope he just you
know people you know you have to
understand that some folks are like that
but they're living a lot myself to
sticking their head in the sand they
need to get it out and and do it I
appreciate you said it there dear thank
you so much actually that both of the
judges in Kirk's case agreed to spend a
lot of time talking to me when I was
researching the book and both of them
expressed sorrow over the verdict and
for the fact and student talk to me do
also they that's true also the the juror
the foreperson of Kirk's second trial
appeared with Kirk on Oprah and publicly
apologized correct right around some and
I love that man to death yes ma'am
I just wanted to know who's sponsoring
Congress about 38 senators I think isn't
John Edwards your senator he's one of
them
he's one of them yep and my one of my
senators Paul sarbanes and Maryland and
2036 others are supporting and Senator
Leahy we it's got bipartisan support
from senator hats from Utah and you know
he's horrible Republican and but he he
knew you know he don't want nobody to be
innocent in jail like like me or rape
victims and neither test done and he
supported me getting a lot of support
from from the hill and I got I want to
applaud you know since I'm down here to
to Senator Edwards he wouldn't be her
next breath president yes wait for the
mic mister Bloodworth they um right
ready the two prosecutors who withheld
exculpatory evidence in mr. gales case
which put him on death row for five
years have been engaged today all day
today we expect all day tomorrow in
disciplinary hearings before the North
Carolina State Bar they have admitted
that they withheld the exculpatory
evidence but they defended their actions
by saying we didn't read the file we
didn't know that this information was in
the file because we didn't read it and
we really weren't prepared to understand
what exculpate ory evidence was so it's
sort of the deaf dumb and blind defense
ignorance isn't it things that that's
that's right
anyway we're quite concerned the people
in the criminal defense community are
quite concerned that the State Bar is
not going to really take any meaningful
sanction against these prosecutors and I
was just wondering from a personal
perspective what do you think is the
appropriate sanction for these
prosecutors should they be prosecuted
criminally if the State Bar does not
take action against them well that would
have to be up to mr. Gill here I mean I
think he definitely got a case and also
personally I think it should be
disbarred that's just my opinion I mean
you know if you run a stop sign
don't say you see it but you go and do
you're gonna hit a truck and that's what
they did
you got some running to do
yes sir before you leave this world is
there any change to the justice system
that if came about would make you feel
it was worthwhile the years that were
stolen from you by the justice system to
not have Alan gales in prison or Kris
Conover's or Kirk Bloodsworth ever again
and quite frankly as long as that could
happen they need to hold a death penalty
out to sea tonight so I don't know if
it's in there but I was curious if it's
written in the book how you met your
wife and if not can you tell us that's a
secret actually it is just kid don't
tell about yes yes some will talk babe
you gotta be specialist stick with me Oh
that was beautiful one of the things
that you spoke about was what life was
like in the penitentiary and I'm
wondering the kind of treatment that you
received being in this place where your
life was in danger where the temperature
was always wrong it was way too hot or
way too cold it sounds like that you
were tortured basically on a day-to-day
basis and I have a sense that that's
what prison life is life like for a lot
of people can you speak to this the
injustice of incarceration in general
even for people who have committed their
crime well you know you're sent to
prison as punishment not for punishment
you know what I mean you can't be
punished more than taking away from
society and you know people fret I mean
that's something to be taking away from
society these places are brutal they
live by a code they live we all live by
a code in there I mean and a lot of
people don't follow that code especially
the people running it and you know you
can't you you're two sides pit against
each other and it's a sweat box it's hot
it's brutal the guys in there and so
let's face it that's why we got prisons
to keep people like that there but and
somehow somewhere people who take power
and they just you know they get big in
on this power trip and they start doing
things like closing the windows and
stuff like that I mean that's just mall
compared to some of the stuff we've seen
you know I've seen guards go right down
on a man and almost choke him right out
and in whether you're innocent or guilty
no person no person not in our society
should have to deal with that because
that's putting ourselves down to their
level and I don't think that's right and
as long as we have that in this world we
need to stop doing something to change
it fix it do whatever you can to make
you sing right demand it was on your
shirt wouldn't let let that stuff happen
anybody else yes dear right I really
appreciate you coming tonight because I
actually am an attorney representing
someone on death row right now who's
innocent bless your heart okay and I
think you said that was someone said you
the first person exonerated I happen to
teach a class yesterday I had the list
of 116 people that have been exonerated
only uh only a handful of them really
got exonerated on count of DNA right
it's like 5% and what worries me is
knowing firsthand that I've been trying
to fight for a guy for the past eight
years and getting nowhere because of the
same kind of the same kind of problems
that you face and you know I just wanted
to let people know 116 people and
Counting because as a criminal defense
attorney
I cringe at wondering how many other
people are there that don't have
attorneys willing you know four eight
nine years to keep fighting for them or
have clients like yourself that keep
fighting for themselves well you know to
add to what you're saying there's 3,500
people on death row throughout the
United States and according to the
current statistics since 1976 from those
have been released and exonerated
one out of eight are innocent one out of
eight you wouldn't take a bus ride if it
was going to crash one out of eight
times with you and well you know I'm not
trying to be flippers it mean it's the
facts these things are laid right out
form and the powers that be in some of
the judicial circles and political
circles seem to think that that's we're
not tough on crime this is a death
penalty book notice it and this is an
innocent book this is about innocent man
as his life and there is many many
people one sitting right down one in the
back and who knows how many people have
been executed over the years and if we
can't get it right turn out the light
just stop it you know I'd rather put
them in prison at least they're going to
have a chance to try to get out
someday and I applaud your efforts dear
and I hope you succeed in saving that
man's life one way or the other I would
like to have Alan jeal tell us what he
is doing now I'm very impressed with the
turn that his life is made would you
tell us that please beware this year
I've been working really hard on getting
North Carolina to pass a moratorium on
executions I hope everybody in here some
Foreman knows what it is if not it's a
two-year hold on executing people here
in North Carolina while we look at some
of the problems we have with our system
it's been to me it seems like it's been
going fairly well getting support for
the moratorium and I think we'll
probably get it past recession but on us
something that I've been working on and
also now I'm a full-time student trying
to get a degree so I can practice Social
Work I want to be a social worker kind
of dedicate my life to helping others
but that's basically what I've done for
the first six months it was spent solely
on trying to get the moratorium passed
now I'm doing both working on getting it
passed and going to school